- Like a (racing car sound)
- Yeah (laughing)
- Hey guys, this
is the Other Show.
I'm Chris and this is?
- Sarah, hi.
- And we're here to talk
about episode nine which is
pretty dark, yeah.
- Jason drops his first album.
It's the plain bottle episode.
- Yes.
We're here with Drew and
Helene and Molly Shannon.
- Whoo, Molly Shannon!
- Yeah.
- I know you get a
full name at all times.
- You know if this
plane goes down,
the headline's gonna read,
Chase Dreams comma others
die in plane crash.
We are comma others.
- Well, first of all,
- Yeah.
- If we were on a
plane, it would say
Molly Shannon comma
others die in plane crash.
(laughing)
- Without question.
- The example that we had
in the show that we cut
was if Oprah and
Beyonce, this is morbid,
but were on the same
flight that crashed,
- Jesus.
- [Chris] Who would get
top billing?
- I think Oprah.
- I think Oprah, too, right?
- But what if it was the day
after Formation came out?
- Ooh.
- [Drew] Very tough.
- Wait, somebody in
the writer's room said
that they would put out
two different editions
of the paper that day.
- [All in Unison]
Yeah (laughing)
- Like collector's editions
where you'd get to choose
whose your top billing.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Can Oprah die?
- Oh (laughing).
- That's a good question.
- [Girls] Chase,
Chase, Chase, Chase.
(screaming)
- So we shot this
episode for four days,
and we had a bunch
of kids on the plane
but not all kids could
come for all four days.
They were only allowed to
I guess to legally work
for two days, or something.
So they hired only twins.
- Only identical twins.
- [Chris] So everybody on the
plane is an identical twin,
So in acts one and
two, it's one twin
and then in act three,
where you start screaming,
it's their twin.
- Whoa.
- That's crazy cause we
got to there we were like,
hi, like we knew them
and they were like, "hi".
- One twin is gonna
be like, I don't know,
it's like a fun party
and the other one
is gonna be like, are you sure?
This woman was just screaming
about her husband's dick.
Is this the same show?
- So you what I
think might help?
- Helen.
(pig screaming)
- I don't want to hold your pig.
- Okay well can you, because
she's getting really heavy?
- As soon as I held
Helen, it screamed.
It could just tell I
had bad energy maybe.
- Ken was kind of like,
the Helen whisperer.
And Kate was like
- Yeah.
- Putty in his hands
and then the hand off
would happen and the
screaming would begin.
(laughing)
- The pig was very happy,
very well taken care of.
- Yes it was.
- Yes of course.
- And the pig's owner
was really nice.
I got, I became very
friendly with her.
- Yeah.
- We texted one another.
- We had one experience
on SNL where we needed
a squirrel, and this
handler was like
"Yes, I have a trained squirrel
and we'll bring it to you.
"The squirrel does what I say.
"It will do whatever you need."
- And also, you really
have to shoot at night
because the squirrel is
driving down from the capital.
(laughing)
- So it was eight
hours in a truck.
- Driven down, the squirrel
was put on its mark,
the camera started rolling,
the squirrel immediately
just ran up into the rafters,
(laughing)
- And then the squirrel's
trainer was like,
"We just have to wait
for it to come down."
(laughing)
- She was like, "What do we do?
"What should we do?"
We were like, "I don't
know what should we do?"
(laughing)
- They were sort of like,
"Well, you know with a squirrel,
you know, you can train
it, but you also just like,
you actually can't."
(laughing)
- You actually can't.
- It's a wild animal so
it's gonna do what it wants.
- You can train it,
but on the other hand,
you cannot train it.
(laughing)
- I'm not gonna tell Chase.
And starting tomorrow,
my name's Roberta,
you're Felicia, Carrie's Dante,
Chase is Miguel, we
move to South America,
we start over.
- What?
- I think my favorite
scenes to shoot
were the scenes that we
went into the bathroom.
So like watch Molly
slowly disintegrate.
- [Chris] Yeah.
- But we would do them
out of order and stuff
and you're so amazing in it.
- Yeah.
- And all of us falling
apart at different times.
But like watching
you sort of like
have the veneer come
off is really awesome.
- That was a big
chunk to memorize.
And we were shooting
you know in New York,
and I stayed at a, I
think it was a Hilton,
to memorize my monologue.
I went swimming and there
was like a glass like window,
so there was a prom going
on while I was memorizing.
So I was swimming,
memorizing my lines,
waiving to people
like at a prom.
- [Sarah] For real?
(laughing)
- Dragging that scene.
- Molly Shannon is swimming
and screaming to herself?
- And I swam for so
long because there was
so much to memorize
that when I got out
I had a charley
horse, and I was like,
I hope the prom
people don't see me.
(laughing)
- I had to scoot up to the.
- That's going to
be their prom story.
They're gonna be
like, at my prom
I went to a dance and
I saw Molly Shannon
coming out of a pool,
just like falling apart.
- So let's all have a laugh.
Let's all laugh at
my dead husband.
- Molly no one's
laughing, it's okay.
- He was the only
man I ever loved.
I did not want him to
be a ***ing joke.
- In the first episode,
it says I miss Dad,
and we were like yeah,
and I know I did too.
But we didn't decide
what that meant.
- Yeah.
- It's so it was
like fun to figure
out in the room what
happened to him.
- Yeah.
- We also went back through,
kind of when we were
towards the end, and
added the year of yes
for a line for Pat's character.
That was kind of like
a later in the game.
Because we really
liked this idea that
we've seen her existing
through this whole season
kind of like
repressing and making
this new narrative for herself
as like a gung ho
woman going for it.
And then in this episode
where she finally
let's that go the side,
it's very satisfying
to see that woman give it up.
- [Cast In Unison] Yeah.
- I love the part
where she's like
where she just says,
explains why she didn't want
to tell Chase that
she's just like,
I just want him
to have a chance.
It's like so heartbreaking.
And then I just loved how
dignified she is with the way
she sees him, how hard he
did try and so respectful.
And I guess being
an Irish Catholic
with a long history of
alcoholics in my family
I just felt like it was
just ****ing beautiful.
- I didn't want to give a
sheet or it to be a joke,
I didn't want like
people to decide
- No
- [Chris] Who he was for him.
- A joke, that's
horrible, yeah, no.
- It's also not so cut
and dry, any of this.
That alcoholism and
anything is never just,
he was a loser,
he was a bad guy.
It's never that cut and dry.
So it's nice to tell
multi sides to that story.
- Exactly, yeah, multiple
sides to the story.
I've never performed anything
like that in my life.
I love it, I loved it.
It was like (kissing sound)
(techno music)